the federal government
has invoked the emergencies act
to supplement provincial and territorial
capacity to address the blockades
and occupations
i want to be very clear the scope of
these measures will be
time limited
geographically targeted
as well as reasonable
and proportionate
to the threats they are meant to address
the emergencies act will be used to
strengthen and support law enforcement
agencies
at all levels across the country
this is about keeping canadians safe
protecting people's jobs
and restoring confidence in our
institutions
we're entering the third week of illegal
blockades that have been disrupting the
lives of too many canadians
here in our capital city families small
businesses have been enduring illegal
obstruction of their neighborhoods
occupying streets
harassing people breaking the law
this is not
a peaceful protest at the borders in
different parts of the country the
blockades are harming our economy and
endangering public safety
critical supply chains have been
disrupted
this is hurting workers who rely on
these jobs to feed their families